and every relationship there's a bull
and a cow
and just so happens that in this
relationship right here with me and you
I'm the bull you're the cow all right
bull cow
hi I'm Ben Affleck
original gangsters gangster discovery
today I know what we have to do
please don't say we've all gotta have
sex together
like that cuz I get about yeah I know
and I'll be waiting you brought me home
something stand by my end of the deal
I'm gonna walk away I don't want to ask
you for anything but I just want to know
why we don't mind such simple things at
Puritan ideals and they so paranoid
about their bodies in the good and the
bad i impact and go to the beach I back
off my bones see look at it I don't care
I'm sorry about the way I'm acting be
better now why
hey just as if arranged it's not a good
actor Batman's from Gotham Ben Affleck's
in Boston don't make no sense
Gotham is not a real place you know